Hello everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Today we will do a new episode
of Challenge Pongfinity
Let's see what kind of challenges you have come up with this time!
We have attached a racket to a stick
This is one of the world's longest table tennis rackets probably
Let's see if we can play with it.
That's a really good spin actually!
Nice one!
I'm finding the rhytm!
It's like you would be canoeing!
Exactly!
It's not working so well!
Next is an Instagram challenge from Jonny Winns
He wants us to play with a table
I think that it is the biggest racket that I have ever used!
This is how you play table tennis with a table!
I should have got that shot also
But no can do!
Last time we sliced an apple
This time we will try a banana!
No.
This is not going to work.
Nope.
It's not going to happen.
I did it!
That was a perfect hit!
Look at that!
Straight in the middle!
There is the banana!
Remember to subscribe to our channel here
And watch our previous videos there!
Until next time!